pan on start toasting those spices to
keep the pan nice and low cubing very
aromatic very fragrant and someone's
like a life spice next nice little
coriander seeds coriander in now you
gotta get a bit of heat in the chutney
mustard seeds are smaller than coriander
seeds but so much more powerful mustard
seeds you now curry leaves don't
actually smelled much dry but the
flavour they give off is extraordinary
coli's in reading perform afterburner
otherwise you'll have that bitter taste
across the chutney keep the gas nice and
load the secret is sort of toasting them
so releases that oil and intensifies the
spice touch of salt and then cup of
smooth powerful chilies keep them whole
no one's gonna eat them but it gives
that real nice burst of heat now let
them toast gently there what other chop
the onion we're gonna grate it why
because it sort of breaks down a really
nice puree in the chutney when you grate
it hold the root in the palm of your
hand and just push nice long straight
one of those nice long shards look I've
always got a nice sort of onion puree
but it's nice and clear a touch of olive
oil spices nicely toasted onions in
three nice cloves of garlic lightly
crushed up
lay it nice and flat and just sliced the
guy nice thin slices garlic in
taking your time to get the owners
caramelized beautifully or really reap
rewards in the long run Tamron pace the
sugar in with the sugar first to be nice
tablespoons of sugar that will give a
very nice syrup effect sort of nice rich
syrupy texture to the Chuck tamarind
paste you can get tamarind paste in most
delis and the big supermarkets it's
really nice Fignon Asian but it gives
that tartness to chutney and it's sort
of Bridge sugary spicy
next in with my coconut I'd pour nice
tablespoons that will give a nice body a
really nice texture to the Chapman Kubat
coconut out and now and the carrot
grated the carrot just gives the chutney
nice sort of crunch but also helps to
sort of cool down the spiced carrot in
the water comes out of the carrot
flavors the chuckling usually but gives
that nice sort of vibrant bright color
to it as well
and grating it almost sort of it cooks
instantly but I want a bit of texture
through here turn down the gas and just
let that simmer for five minutes
if the carers are that moist and juicy
then come a tablespoons of water in
there to help it along now just cut that
out for five minutes just as those
carrots they'll go nice and soft don't
overcook them you want that nice texture
in there slightly spicy slightly sweet
gas off keep those chilies in there for
that it's beautiful
nice and gooey delicious and ready to go
and his jar was that sits in the fridge
just gets better and better and better I
love to eat this chutney with cold meats
or even cold fish
but with ham it's amazing
it's a really nice way of labelling up
the ham just sort of roll it up get a
nice spoon of chutney I mean it looks
fantastic
chutney onto the plate and serve that is
a nice little gem in the fridge but it's
worth prepping in advance for I want the
crispiness on the top the puree on the
bottom of the camera and then a texture
up of the skin
pull it back nice and slowly